we're now known as the land of rapes but
did you ever wonder how this took shape
don't shy away now you're a part of this
culture of lawyers who will kill and
politicians who banner will and all the
other blood sucking vultures
both functioning and I have faced some
of the issues that have come up in our
video so we said let's be the voice for
other women who might not be able to
speak about it let's be the voice and
let's encourage everybody to sort of
start talking about it
stop that tweet and actually get up on
your feet and help reform this mindset
that for years has been pre said that
women are nothing more than objects to
be controlled shut up and use so sex no
boy learn some respect